las vegas has always been a leader in
the travel and tourism industry of
course it has thanks in part
to the lvcva now our town really took a
big hit during the pandemic but we're
making that comeback and everybody knows
the house always wins baby lori nelson
craft
she is the senior vice president of
communications for the lvcva
she's joining us live to talk more about
our city's recovery
lori good morning to you thank you so
much for bringing this great news today
it is so exciting to be back with you
and to really be talking about
pent up demand yeah absolutely
apple or vegas yeah i gotta tell you
walk out of the front door of channel 8
here this is what's cool about working
here now
your house is right the lvcda the las
vegas convention center is right across
the street
and it is fabulous let's talk about the
big shows that are coming to town that
are going to enjoy that new
part of the las vegas convention center
right well as you you mentioned we went
through
a beautiful expansion it is ready to
debut
we're going to open the 1.4 million
square foot expansion to the convention
center
by welcoming the world of concrete in
early june that's one of our
key marquee shows that is coming back to
las vegas
and we're really excited once you
once we open the doors to world of
concrete we have
30 more shows on the moon before end of
this year
yeah and that means jobs lori and that's
one of the things that i love about this
town
when we have a new property when there's
new folks coming in anything new
that means jobs that means our economy
is going up so great to hear that
let's talk about the tourism you guys
have a new campaign for tourism
and also for business travelers tell us
all about that
right so we're getting back into the mix
really promoting travel
really inviting everyone back now the
destination has fully reopened
so from a business standpoint the
convention industry is
incredibly important to the destination
um this is our sunday through thursday
business we recently launched a new
campaign called
fast forward really talking about
reinventing the way
people meet um the new sites the new
technologies the new sounds
and this week as well we are getting
back out to talk to our
leisure visitors you guys will be
hearing more um i know you have fletch
coming in tomorrow to actually talk
about it
but it's our new national campaign that
we'll be uh
debuting to let out the vegas in you and
it really kind of plays off
the what happens here only happens here
and so we're getting out aggressively we
know there's pent-up demand for travel
and we know that on the short list is
las vegas and
all of our resort partners are excited
to keep welcoming visitors back as
as they're ready to uh plan their next
videos yeah not only on the short list
is on everybody's list the long ones the
short ones the in-between ones everybody
wants to come to vegas so you guys like
i said earlier you're debuting that
beautiful extension 989 million dollars
how many square feet i'm sorry y'all are
killing it right now
well thank you uh this was in the works
for
many many years um there has always been
talk of
the way you can grow visitation is
through the meeting and convention
industry and so
throughout the entire destination our
west hall expansion which
literally is steps away from chattel at
88 news now
at 1.4 million square feet total
the overall destination has 14 million
square feet
of event and meeting space this is a
beautiful contemporary space
you'll notice a lot of natural light we
have
um an outdoor terrace with views of the
strip
that will allow you to host events
upwards of 2000 people
and we just think it's going to be a
game changer in the meeting
and event industry and it makes las
vegas convention center the second
largest convention center in the united
states
that is amazing it's so much fun living
here and hearing all this great news
lori
i got uh less than a minute now tell us
about this new the loop we've been
hearing about it you know
everybody's been doing the stories about
the loop and everybody's ready for it
i'm a little claustrophobic so i ain't
all that excited but everybody else is
the uh we're we're transporting our
guests
in a quick and fun way thanks in
partnership to elon musk's the boring
company
uh our campus is now over a mile long
walk so we wanted a fun way to transport
our guests from one end of the
convention center to the other
and you're looking at it now in less
than two minutes you can go
across the whole campus and better than
that
this application here is going to go
destination wide in the coming years
we're in the early stages through the
boring company
of getting approvals to go from downtown
to the strip
to as far south as a legion stadium and
eventually the airport
very cool like i said i'm loving it i'm
loving all of it hey lori it is so good
seeing you folks i i gotta be honest
with you laurie and i have been knowing
each other for
about 14 15 years now so she's moved to
a different venue since the last we
talked so it's really great seeing you
this morning thank you for joining me
for mondays with monica and
we'll have to do lunch real soon i would
love that monica thank you
all right take care and hey folks don't
forget to catch my moj show facebook
live show weeknights at 7 p.m
and you can catch the replay right here
on eight news now
in the 4 30 p.m show so sherry you got a
couple ways to do that but isn't it cool
you guys have worked here for many years
sharon i know you specifically
you can walk out the front door and go
over to the las vegas convention center
excuse me
well you know it is great to it is a
beautiful facility
um and and it's gorgeous to look at
before all those people come crowding in
on convention center drive
monica we tried to get them to get a
tunnel to come right over to channel 8
so that we could just go ride the tunnel
back and forth because
once all those people start coming it's
all over the employees may not be able
to get in and out of work here in
general
it's gonna get crowded out there listen
i would take selfies in front of this
place ladies and gentlemen if you get a
chance to check it out it is
absolutely stunning but that's what they
do here in vegas yeah they do